leute warum bin ich single große frage
die ich mir selbst 20.000 milliarden
menschen gestellt habt die ihr euch
vielleicht auch schon gestellt habt
deswegen werden wir die heute denn ich
habe ein video bei einem englischen die
tür glaub ich gesehen bin ich dafür
einfach das ist ein geiles ding probier
ich selbst mir aus könnt euch die seiten
verlinken beschreibung heißt wegen test
machen wollt könne das auch machen
wir legen jetzt los ward senior fred
right now was ist momentan in meinem
kühlschrank des kontinents was den
kontinent zu kontinent in soßen oder
fleischkäse und works überbleibsel von
essenslieferungen nur bio obst und
gemüse eine packung verdorbene mich da
würde ich sagen schau mal nach kirchen
dass oettinger spricht sie von so viel
erreicht im letzten video kritisiert
wurde
vanille sauce wähle ich jetzt überhaupt
ziemlich gut ist fitter elfte 2016
dicker wieso so gut an uns was haben wir
hier kaffee brot käse sahne bier wein
protein käse oder salatsauce alter aber
ansonsten haben wir auch in salaten aus
vorgaben halte ich überein und bücher
würde ich sagen aber zu meiner
verteidigung hier noch äpfeln okay also
immer auf jeden fall nicht nur soßen
fleisch käse gab es kommt am nächsten in
ihrem so krank viel käse im kühlschrank
dem wir das hier faules fläche wie lang
war meine letzte beziehung
es gibt für option ein paar wochen ein
paar monate ein jahr ein paar jahre als
nation chips one hyde
also wir am wochen monate ein jahr
mehrere jahre hat noch nicht der
richtige beziehung und es war deine nach
zwinker zwinker
das nehmen wir
okay sagen wir dass es vielleicht ein
stück das ist so eine sache also eine
ernste beziehung ernste beziehung wenn
ich jetzt sehr sehr kritisch sein würde
dann könnten wir noch anders antworten
ja ist ruhm clean
bis jetzt sind wir jetzt gerade sauber
jetzt noch
ja es liegt recht viel chic hier rum
würde ich sagen
also wenn dieser mann vieles hier der
baronin jay brown sich jeder turner up
der boni wie gesagt es steht viel zeug
kommt viel zurück kommen aber es ist
sauber ich habe auf jeden fall heute
morgen erst gesagt also der spitze
stehen leute dann auch da nichts mein
ruhm ist ja mein zimmer sauber uk wo
gehst du beim ersten date drinks also
getränken döner essen abendessen the
movies heißt ins kino noch mehr optionen
oder ein konzert ist mir scheißegal
und mein bedroom motto erstes date
direkt im schlafzimmer kann sich auch
auf weit über die nachrichten
unterhalten
wo will ich beim ersten date hingehen
bringst deine kino kino habe ich früher
gemacht als ich noch jünger war war ich
dann megawatt wusste nicht was ich mit
mir das reden soll dass wir da bin ich
immer ins kino gegangen da nicht reden
muss und auch so keine ahnung sich näher
kommen kann
erst mitte oder mit irgendwem wohingegen
bei unserem ersten date was immer in
mein schlafzimmer konzert finde ich
persönlich auf keinen fall drinks mahmud
drinks schön mit der alten einen saufen
sieht man auch wie trinkfest ist ob die
was kann am glas sehr wichtig natürlich
nicht wann hast du das letzte mal
geduscht heute morgen letzte nacht vor
ein paar nächten ich schwitze nicht oder
ich glaube da kommt noch ein paar option
ohne ein weil natürlichen öle
wahrscheinlich ich war jemals von parfüm
gehört ok jetzt verstehe ich auch warum
manche leute wirklich sehr lange single
sind wenn sie solche fragen beantworten
ist will ich jetzt ungerne enttäuschen
leute und ich würde sehr gerne antwort
nämlich zu trennen
wie meinen natürlichen öle waschen mich
selbst aber es war tatsächlich
nebelschütz wahr gemacht wähle das ding
was für dich am wichtigsten ist freunde
meinen glauben jedenfalls seien hier
musste eine familie geld meinen job los
mit dem entscheidet würde sagen ich
würde sagen ich würde sagen ich würde
sagen freunde familie geldsanktionen
youtube oder sowas
metlife youtubes datenoption ich würde
ganz ehrlich sagen familie glaube ich
glaube ich bin nicht gläubig freunde
auch sehr wichtig sehr wichtig finde ich
geld auch sehr wichtig - auch sehr
wichtig aber ganz ehrlich familie und
wenn dann richtig zufällig wird abgesagt
denn nun seine familie am tisch auch
ohne geld gern und zu guter letzt sei
ehrlich glaubst überhaupt dann wahre
liebe ja nein vielleicht alter was sind
das für philosophische fragen man sich
bei let's play sollen läuft jetzt
beantworten wir irgendwelche buzzfeed
crysis und müssen sehr tief
philosophische fragen beantworten ob wir
an die wahre liebe glauben yes no
dies sei als es längst über ich würde
aber ganz ehrlich sagen leute das klingt
bis hin was ihr kind so komisch das
klingt nicht komisch aber ich würde ganz
ehrlich ein gefühle sagen nein
aber irgendwann auswählen deswegen sage
ich einfach mal ich sag jetzt mal ja
ganz ehrlich es ist hier dass die
resultate
du hast bekommen youtube bett offen bis
du bist zu böse du bist eine zu böse
schlange
du bist eine böse [ __ ] verdammt böse
im michael jackson sinne
ich meine du solltest sieben singles aus
deinem album releasen so böse bist du
wie ich mich wegen der fülle zu bett zu
bett
du bist viel zu böse bis viel zu böse um
von einem verdammten oder abgepackten
freund oder freundin zurück gehalten zu
werden lädt dich frei aus du böseste
[ __ ] lebt dich frei aus was das
helle alter bis es kein gültiges
ergebnis dass mir nicht als böse
[ __ ] bezeichnet
what the [ __ ] buzzfeed ich bin männlich
wenn menschliches individuum ohne wenn
und aber okay und dann lass mir nichts
erzählen von wegen ich bin eine böse
[ __ ] oder eine bitte die website wet
t shirt an yukon bay ja leute ich weiß
nicht was das resultat was ich erwartet
habe in meinem leben am heutigen tage
auf dieser website aber es ist irgendwie
so tat vielleicht ist ja auch mal
gemacht habt und euch verlinkt in der
beschreibung macht ihn einfach mal guckt
ob ihr auch eine böse schlappe seit
vielleicht haben wir das ja gemeinsam
und ja bis zum nächsten video